The first thing I want to say about
high performance computing is that it's
the dumbest name ever.
I mean, like seriously?
High performance?
As opposed to what exactly?
Low performance?
Unfavourable performance?
Sober performance?
2.5 out of 4 stars performance?
So I went and I talked to a bunch of my
colleagues from all over the world, and
I asked each one of them,
what do you think about HPC?
One of them, John Shalf, from Lawrence
Berkeley National Labs, had this to say.
>> Well first off,
I like to call it super computing.
HPC sounds kind of boring.
Super computing, now that is compelling.
>> Well said, John.
I couldn't agree more.
So with that, let's go super compute.
[SOUND]